i can't believe i'm getting to do this
segment with you i've been on the chew
with you i always act so enthusiastic i
think they're gonna kick me off
because i'm like bananas that i'm with
you guys and i have
we loved having you because you were
always fun you were
always fun and you always brought it and
when in the beginning when no
celebrities
they're like what is this stupid show we
don't want to come on here you were one
of the first people that came on for us
which really opened the doors and
everybody was like oh it's okay drew did
it it's okay
oh i'm so glad i mean i felt like i was
entering like
a rock star forum but chefs are rock
stars
and i also have seen almost every
episode of iron chef since the inception
of it
i do miss looking for the next iron chef
because the caliber of chefs
and the food was one of the most
elevated i've ever seen
and i really wish they'd bring that back
because it's just like
oh it's so good drew here's the problem
me and bobby and morimoto we're old now
we we can't run around like that anymore
i'm like i'm like b could you imagine to
an iron chef he's like oh the bones
would not hold up we'd go down in a heap
i'm like
it's true we have diminishing skills
we're like uh football players that are
past their pride
and yet you're always coming out with
new shows i mean how many shows do you
have on food network
right now like three well you know we
yeah we did
um simon's dinners uh myself and lizzy
we actually
shot it during the pandemic in our
backyard simon dinner's cooking out and
our friend
olivia shot the whole show on her iphone
so
um we did that and then i have burgers
brew and q
oh yeah um and then me and flay our work
we uh we did our barbecue show last year
we're gonna do another one this year
that we're getting ready to film so
you know staying busy and then they're
showing all those shows on discovery
plus now too including some of the old
like cook like an iron chef and that
kind of stuff so that's fun well it's
all under the discovery network which
has
you know national geographic and food
network and hgtv
so they've got all of us sucked in they
really know what people
want don't they my goodness they're
gonna have magnolia network on
oh my gosh where would we be without all
of this seriously
i know freaking out in the corner um
lizzie you mentioned
is your wife yes and i love how you guys
met
uh you work together and
then well you tell me well you know we
worked together
uh we met almost 30 years ago uh
at a restaurant um as i tell everybody
when we met at the restaurant she was a
manager and i was a cook so
you know 30 plus years ago she was my
boss and which has worked out perfectly
for our marriage because she still is
[Laughter]
i like that um and and you guys like
were
working at another restaurant and you
suggested that maybe she
work at that and then you guys work
together again and that's
yeah so like i left to take a chef job
somewhere else and then
the front of the house was a hot mess
and you know liz is a
you know a wine beverage expert and so
she does the beverage programs in the
and the design four of our restaurants
so i lured her in to come work with me
at this restaurant we ran that
restaurant together and then we opened
lola together which was uh gosh 24 years
in march
is when we opened lola so it's been a
it's a institution one of the most
accoladed
and award-winning restaurants in
cleveland
anywhere in the country but it is yeah
we had a
we had a spectacular run we you know
unfortunately it closed during the
pandemic
uh you know it's life that everybody's
going through right now and you just
kind of figure it out but
um 24 if someone would have told me 24
years ago you're going to open this
restaurant it's going to last for 24
years not a chance i would have never
thought it would happen
you know we were kids then but it's been
a terrific run
if someone like michael simon and lola
that wins james beards and just every
award
that a chef in a restaurant can win a
24-year run
what is and it's so hard to put it
succinctly of course because it's such a
complex
issue what do you say to chefs that are
just starting out and unfortunately in
this time is there
any you know i would say that there's i
think there's going to be tremendous
opportunities for
moving forward you know uh eventually
we're going to get through this pandemic
we're going to be moving in the right
direction and then they're going to have
great
opportunities again to to start and grow
and and new businesses and um you know
the the restaurant business is is you
know you know who's someone who
frequents them and loves them so much is
it's resilient and and it will
it will fight back and it will do
everything that it's always done and
um it'll find its way it's a hard time
for right now but it's a hard time for
the country right now so
we'll get there we'll definitely get
there i do in my optimistic
ways believe that out of the hardest and
darkest times will come
some of the greatest expression the most
abundant business
the greatest innovation you talked about
doing your show on an iphone in your
backyard like
this is where we innovate we come
together
and we start to thrive